there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock what's up everybody its
episode 148 yeah now on this one you
know how for a while I was kind of like
you know doing true crime one week and
then paranormal stuff that the next week
that's kind of what we're doing today um
so I was gonna say that this is probably
gonna be like oh it's kind of a more
paranormal show cuz it's about purported
demon possessions and so it'll be more
fun but then the second case we're gonna
talk about not so fun but true crime
also this is paranormal and true crimes
yes cuz at least the second cases yeah
evidently dude got possessed and did all
kinds of screwed up stuff you know
involved some eatin somebody's face kind
of kind of like Florida man down here
who took Flocka and eight other got
naked with the other dude ate his face
off in front of hospital like you do now
that was the one that was on the
security footage yes yeah you couldn't
see it happens just saw him down in
between the dividers at this concrete
dividers keep the traffic from you know
hitting one another in the oncoming lane
is that that's how they got down in
there they were naked yeah [ __ ] I don't
know why [ __ ] it does weird things to
the mind I guess I started fighting and
due-date the other guy's face then they
were reported zombies I remember all the
jokes yes there's this dude lived - the
guy who got his face eaten he live this
islam yeah yeah he's a bomb - bombs
that's not I mean it's like you know
it's bad enough that you're like
homeless and you're probably had a
shitty life and then some dude comes
along on flaca
choose your face off and then you gotta
live your rest of your bum life they
were both high on floppies [ __ ] - no I
think they were both high on Flocka last
night you've got high together on flaca
you guys are no [ __ ] is flaca
you okay just to just go on YouTube this
type in Flocka and you'll see just it
just makes me will do the weirdest [ __ ]
all kinds of fun kind of repeat the same
things over and over again like let's
dance yeah yeah it's real cheap after I
heard that it came in like potpourri and
bath salts this Psalm in those you know
ghetto drug stores they sneak it in and
you buy bath salts and I guess you smoke
it see with that guy
here's the thing though and I don't like
please correct me if I'm wrong so it's
not like I've like kept up with this new
survey or anything but I thought like I
remember hearing about examine was like
ooh zombie apocalypse this is how it
starts it's just like the beginning
water dead like one duty than some other
dudes everyone just makes joke about it
but I thought that they determined later
on that drugs were not involved because
I remember thinking ha that makes it
like a hundred times more mysterious I
think why the [ __ ] I think I think my
understanding drugs were not detected
but you can't detect [ __ ] I evidently
know I didn't know yeah I think I
thought you couldn't pretty much detect
yeah well you know you're right drugs
you could probably detect it if you have
Flocka but I'm thinking detective
somebody took it or not it's just yeah
the last I heard it was Flocka yeah I
don't know like I said I haven't kept up
with that when you were talking about
like so eating somebody's face up I was
thinking about that poor woman that had
that pet chimpanzee that flipped out and
chewed her friends face off and that
woman lived also yeah so you know she
gets fingers off and shoot above yeah
God dad that chimp was mad well clearly
yeah I might and you know don't get me
wrong I love apes and monkeys and stuff
I've even read I read the biography of
nim chimpsky the very famous little
chimpanzee that was on Sesame Street
like back in the 70s and stuff and as
much as I love them and people were all
they were all like cool about that is a
chancy's though yeah that's what I mean
they're like all these people are like
oh you know we can raise it with a kid
no which you can until they're about
five or six if you're male ma'am
they will just flip out and just tear
your male chimpanzee
these are demons basically demonic
they're cute when they're little and
they're human like when they're little
but what keep the males get to remember
that I shouldn't be a live episode about
that guy went down there and merican guy
went down there to hang out with his
hang out with his African friend who was
yes and they got attacked by that
chimpanzee that testicles right now that
black dude jump right in between those
two dudes and that that chimpanzee
basically just ate that black dude right
in front of him yeah just you know in
any and that white dude said that that
to look into the face of that chimpanzee
so it was like looking in the face of a
demon yeah they're mean they're just
yeah particularly the males and
particularly I think I believe once they
get about eight years old yeah as I said
up until then I mean they're a handful
obviously but some people have raised
them or kept them as pets you know when
they were younger than that but once
they reach that age particularly males
yeah you know we can't keep them in your
house you know what it's like to see
something that makes you mad you go yeah
you know I mean look when a chimp does
that I mean it's it's like tenfold well
in there like massive time stronger than
a person actually that's a myth did you
know that is it yeah to myth there I
looked into that alright cuz you know
maybe I was wishing I had chimpanzee
strike you know turns out that they were
saying they were like it's that whole
thing that they were five times stronger
than the average male kind of came from
early 1900s
when there wasn't much physical fitness
in people but whatever it was that
noodle arm yeah people didn't wait work
out yeah yeah you know in a situation
like that you put a lot of muscle on a
small frame yeah and if they have a lot
of leverage because their bones aren't
very long you know compared to human in
there they're kind of compact and
they'll jump on a late Victorian early
20th century man just tear him the [ __ ]
up and his monocle will go for you hang
his top you'll go flying in the opposite
direction
chimpanzee pound-for-pound you get him
to try to do certain things like you
know bench press or whatever lifts
certain weights they're actually just
you know pound for pound about us about
as strong as a guy who works out but
they probably still kick most people's
ass yeah yeah
and a proper pounder no there's a rage
factor though too
well that's what I was just gonna yeah
when adrenaline and stuff kicks in they
don't have any concept no I go I
shouldn't do this or they'll hurt
themselves today don't give one single
no-no and they have teeth they can bite
where they have a you know their bite
forces a lot more than a human and they
do a lot of damage with biting you by to
hand off yeah FEMA can't do that but
when it comes to moving things with like
their upper body and picking things up
and that then things are about as strong
as a strongman yeah you know although
like I said it's probably their their
bite that it's not because I mean I've
seen grandma get [ __ ] up by a dog like
that was you know oh it was really head
up to get in oh man like a 20 20 pounds
20 pound Bob cattle just [ __ ] you up
that's what I mean have to have strong
bite sharp claws but in it with a chip
they go strong bite force they're as
strong as a strong man and they don't
have a filter and when they're pets like
I said they're not worried about going
to prison or no no and I just think that
rage kicks in you know I mean yeah I
mean a person when a person becomes
enraged they can get very strong yeah
yeah chimpanzees have anger issues yes
what it is it's very funny how we went
off on this whole yeah you're right well
just because the second case that we're
talking about in my brain is gonna
encourage some of this someone does get
their face yeah and torn off not by a
chimpanzee though I hear a lot of this
pedestrian talk about oh man a person
who's an angry or you know that's a sign
of weakness and digit like that and oh
you know don't don't give in to anger
you know like that's something about of
Star Wars no mmm guys that trained for
combat trained for physical strength
enhance anger and rage that's how you
get strong and you're lifting weights
you gotta get mean you get mad and you
will push yourself you know them in and
harder and I think it endure it releases
a lot of hormones that are kind of like
performance-enhancing drugs because you
know guys that are constantly mad and
pissed off and work out get big yeah you
know they become war machines yeah so if
you want to get big and you want to get
fierce you can't be Gandhi but yeah well
you know like I said we're gonna talk
about that in the second half of the
show that this case it doesn't have
anything to do with working out it does
everything no anything like that but
about getting mad get mean and getting
demonic and demonically possessed it's
about that or so he said yeah but crazy
people can do it too it's like a crazy
strength that's the same thing yeah yeah
yeah none of me now both of these cases
I talked about both of these cases in my
poltergeist book which was called the
unseen hand they were in the demonic
possession section now I'm gonna say
like right from the jump I do not
believe in demonic possession if
something like quote-unquote paranormal
is going on with these people I think
it's probably some kind of like like I
said some misidentified like poltergeist
yeah which is one of the persons just
crazy right and for any new viewers
imported talking about this before its
name is written a book about it I've
kind of experienced it myself and
out-of-body experience it's also
[Music]
poltergeist it's commonly you know miss
attributed to ghosts it does it is a
ghostly type phenomenon but it's it's
actually RSP k which is recurrent psyche
you know recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis
I know psychokinesis exists I've seen it
it's just I don't really know what it is
yeah and like I said I think that in
cases of demonic possession I think that
it's people like I said it's either
people with mental illnesses in the case
of just someone behaving badly or if
there are other things going on like
strong emotions levitations our [ __ ]
like that that I think that's our s PK
coming from the focus individual but
interpreted through a demonic possession
lens because usually it's people that
are that are already believers just say
good like the the case that inspired the
Exorcist yeah which was what was he
called Robbie Manheim yeah
Roland o or whatever they design their
bees they never like gave his real name
but they saw interviews with one of the
guys that assisted on that and he was a
priest and he was convinced it was RSP k
yeah it sounds like that same yeah and
Jenny's seen it it's not as when you
actually see it happen as an adult you
know it's not as disturbing as you
actually would think it would be it
didn't actually scare me when I saw it I
just thought it was kind of neat like I
didn't like I didn't really believe it
at first like I didn't believe that I
had seen it at first yeah you see it you
can't believe you seen it many yeah yeah
but it was kind of it wasn't like this
big spectacular you know it's kind of
like a Monday and thing like oh remote
jumped off the coffee - yeah it's like
nobody touch that so that was pretty
weird but it didn't scare me I just
thought it was kind of cool yeah that
was very minor yeah you can go back and
look at Mammoth Mountain poltergeist
that's my full story right there the
free to you new listeners yeah but you
know there are other guys that it's
happened to girls gen hops can Hodgkin's
Carson Hodgson that's her name from well
Enfield poltergeist and also um guy want
to have on one of these days the Rain
Man yeah he's in prison John Becker Don
Decker he's out again he might be out by
now that was just for arson right yeah
yeah but it was you know his boss wanted
him to burn the place that's what I mean
well I insurance fraud though I figure
he's probably out yeah he had an ability
to kind of go into a trance and make it
rain indoors just and he said that he
could control it yeah it's unusual yeah
very unusual and he could also kind of
throw himself against walls and somebody
saw him get-get just kind of picked up
by an invisible force
thrown so there's psychokinesis involved
in that too yeah and the cops and the
police were involved in that when the
cops saw rain going sideways and when he
was in prison the first time it was
raining in his cell them
wardens you know had weird stuff
happened to him and the guards were
scared of him and they brought in an
exorcist to come and I guess counseled
him did it they did it exorcism on him
and the raining stopped
that's a dine Decker is a very good case
strange story and mana I'd like to I'd
like to get him on he's he seems like a
very interesting person like all of the
interviews I've seen of him yeah I gotta
try to find him yeah he's probably out
by now cuz I wrote about him in my book
too
yeah but like I said I decided to put
these two cases together just because
excuse me just because they were both
purported cases of demon possession as I
said the first one will kind of do is
like a teaser you know which was just
kind of like a pretty standard
possession it's just it was interesting
because it was attested to by an actual
like psychiatrist and someone who'd been
to like Yale and [ __ ] like that who
actually did believe that it had
occurred and that there was a lot of
witnesses and stuff and then after the
break we'll talk about the really [ __ ]
up one which a couple people have
actually asked me to do yeah so we're
getting around to it yeah and since I
wrote about it my book I said yeah why
not so I decided if we put these two
together is there any business we got to
talk talk about yeah we got a couple of
shout outs this week so let's do that
before we get into the main topic first
thing I wanted to thank Melanie for her
PayPal donation she gives us PayPal
donation so pretty equally and it is
always very much appreciated yeah it's
always a very generous sum thank you
yeah so thank you very much Melanie also
we have a patron named Duane who
actually increased his support up to the
20 dollar level so he will also be
getting a shirt which is another thing
that we've been talking about also if
you didn't see on our patreon page we do
if you're underneath the $20 tier
you still are we put all your names in a
little drawing yes and we did a drawing
so one of you wins a t-shirt and this
time around we do them quarterly this
time around our patron Ashley won a
t-shirt so she will be getting a t-shirt
as well in that tube I'm just waiting on
one thing to actually execute the shirts
but by the time you're seeing this they
may be done yeah we have pretty we have
pretty much everything we have the
screens we have the what do you call the
photo emulsion we have all the stuff I
want a photo hardener and I want this
little plate that will help me apply
yeah that's a no that's coming in a
couple of days and then I'm just waiting
for most of our I think I have eight
people I got back to me so far with
their sizes yeah so if you were a $20
and up patron and you have not got back
to me yet with your sizes please do that
please do that as soon as possible yeah
um you know because that will you know
we want to get the shirt sent out before
the end of the month so we're and we
want everybody to get the size that they
want and whether it's a men's or women's
shirt yeah there's two shirts that I
have right now or that I'm working on
right now one of them is a 13 o'clock
shirt it has me and you on it done it
yeah okay yeah just our loyalty and the
other one is good is a cocoa concert
yeah it's got a Mexican motif yeah
it's kinda it's kind of similar to the
one son or Zazzle store but it's just
like white and it's like a simplified
slightly simplified type of design but
like I said we're hand screen-printing
these every time but we're just gonna
send them up orderly plus eventually
we're gonna set up like an eBay store
where if you want one of the other
designs because I'm eventually gonna end
up having at least four designs
yeah there's two more I got enough to do
two more just we have decided what it's
on yeah yeah we haven't decided I want
to do a faceless bill on one once
everything's ready we're gonna put him
up on the eBay store now somebody
suggested that we do design with baby
cookie on it like she could become like
the mascot what I was thinking now we
had one where it was gonna put something
on the back yeah like a little label
normal there's gonna be a clock with me
and you in it
maybe a thirteen behind that maybe we
have a thirteen with a clock over it and
inside that clock face maybe cookies
face because one thing I wanted to do
I'm like I think that's a really cool
idea like making little baby cookie who
we call food
most of the time making a little cookie
like the the mascot for the show I said
but if we do a cartoon of her I mean yes
her face is adorable but one of her
distinguishing features is her wool
stumpy makes tail yeah so it would have
to be a cartoon where you could see her
a little stumpy thanks oh yeah
that's one of the funniest things I've
ever seen you an are a baby cookie this
[ __ ] up
like I can drop but I haven't done it
for a really long time we're so busy we
don't we don't have time for that anyway
yeah very good but yeah it's probably
wouldn't take that long do a little
cartoon actually we had a fan sent us
one of me and you I kind of I love I
actually would like to have that on a
shirt but I think I don't think I could
do I don't have permission yet well I
could ask her and use it it would have
to be a multi I think it would probably
have to be a multi colored shirt yeah
that might be one that we could sell in
this Apple sazzle store but yeah I
probably want to do three colors at
least yeah because it's so like
intricate and like the colors are dark
and cool and everything and it's like I
don't I think that would like lose a lot
of its coolness if it was just like
printed in white row at average that
means it had to make three different
screens for it yeah that's what I mean
Oh actually it's small like I probably
do two colors on one screen do it twice
yeah another screen would see maybe
maybe you can do a four color version of
it
we'll see yeah we'll see how it goes
like I said you know we do might be
enough yeah white and red or something
we're very excited about doing all this
screen printing stuff by the way I mean
we just we just went the other day and
bought like all the Solvay yeah all the
stuff we haven't bought the shirts yet
because we don't have everyone sizes I
haven't done in a long time but I was
good man I did like a six color one one
time when I was in school just the old
the old way with the exacto blade even
Halon holding this guitar I got from the
cover of Rolling Stone the red one with
all the dolly strikes yeah he's holding
like that it was the cover of a Rolling
Stone magazine I did that in okay yeah I
know you did that an old school silk
street it came out wonderful
I know you're talking yeah just did it
right I can't [ __ ] on you because in my
art class it's like usually we did I
think I did like all these like drawings
and stuff like Morrissey in the cave
yeah the face was perfect
yeah you could yeah you could recognize
exactly that was because I didn't over
detail it was just two colors it was
flesh color in black and the black was
just shat the shadow of his face his
lips his nose in his eyes yeah you know
what I mean so it was this the
suggestion that worked it worked
beautifully
yeah yeah we still have it you know
what's funny is that I only had only had
one copy of it because it was it was for
a grade okay you know and I mean I had
it on a white shirt yeah and somebody
grabbed it cuz because the stranger
school property after I got done they
cut it out and recycled the tree is this
green that's right yeah the frames yeah
but I couldn't say anything you know I
really care well yeah you didn't buy the
frame though anybody wasn't in my stuff
yeah I made this summer I we bought our
rugs and it's green so we can do it
everything oh and that reminds me to of
like one other thing somebody in the
comment section recommended because I
think I think this had to do with the
comment that someone left who was a new
viewer and they said that they loved the
show but they couldn't concentrate
because you were too hot [ __ ] right
and this is I think this was part of
that whole situation and yeah I think
you comment until you shoulda save me
money and somebody and I think too that
we had been talking about you know you
had been talking about like a Bible Camp
and stuff like that like on the last
girl scan yes and somebody recommended
it's like you guys should put pictures
of yourselves in the show when you were
kids so we could see what you look like
yeah put them on it so I'm gonna have to
look what's now you have to send me one
that I'm allowed to use because I don't
know classes ones I got some I know
there's some in this house that I really
I like that baby one of you where you
look like Damien the baby a man which
one was that I don't even remember where
it went to it usually be a little own
frame I don't think around that that
free were probably only like three is
that
that I have in the storage is also a
scanner
maybe yeah that means scan off that or I
can just take a picture of it with my
phone
oh that's modern technology I was just
gonna say it's like what I look at
scanner come on I got a I got a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah I was adorable as a child
everyone will get to see my natural hair
color yeah that'll be a big surprise but
that'll be well I know you guys alright
so um do you want to get to the topic
you doing I'm good alright I'm not you
know I'm not firing on all cylinders yet
yeah this is just the first one we're
recording tonight yeah it wasn't like
last time last time where he had already
like we had already done a movie review
yes like I reckon for like an hour I
went back and watched that it was pretty
good I took a bunch of it out because I
owe a stir I was talking [ __ ]
yeah she was drawn to because we were
and he just kept going off with he's
like flighty a museum man he was going
on and I'm just like please can I end
this show I'm just going off yes woman
drunk though like sometimes we do you
fight yeah it's not not violent fights
but you know yeah she started making fun
of me and [ __ ] in the bar ten years ago
if you get Jenny leave them alone Jenny
our bartenders know it's covered and I'm
sitting there looking like that or I'm
sitting there little on the bar looking
like a broken man and she sits over like
Duff's [ __ ] but you know what though I
didn't dance
aw how it's over with it's over what she
does thing where if I don't dance
exactly when she wants a dance then
she's through I'm through with you but
you don't dance with other people either
you just sit there and go I ain't
dancing with you I remember that [ __ ]
yeah well no but what I was gonna say
that was that are our bartenders I mean
we know we know them really well we've
been going there for years and years
yeah Kylie my son yeah he's a British
guy yeah he calls his mom and dad like
we come in there he's done he's not
quite young enough to be our kid but
almost yeah
yes like him and our other bartender his
name is Tiffany and I love her she's
adorable yeah they always say that they
can tell when tom is drunk but they
can't tell when I ya know Kenny always
seem sober yeah
and she always seems to make sense but
she's not making sense
I'm usually good at keeping but you know
it's gets holier than that when she's
drunk
yeah yeah but she's smarter than me when
she's drunk
I'm always smarter than I'm sober you
watch right into that I got those prize
I set you up for that I set you up for
that one but I gonna spin it that's cool
I got those primal instincts offset your
intelligence though you know time ah
yeah I got all that street wisdom he's
Kirk and I'm Spa exactly it's exactly
exactly that's it I'm Kirk in your spot
yeah [ __ ] that is exactly that's
exactly the day exactly the dynamic [ __ ]
even my ex-husband used to call me Spock
yeah you're not the first persons yeah
yeah I get called that a lot yep that's
exactly what it is all right so let's
talk about some demon possession shall
we hmm all right now this case is
actually fairly recent only happened
about 11 years ago this happened in 2008
this is the case it's just called Julia
we don't know the real name of the woman
at the center of this because she kind
of like didn't want like the guy that
wrote about it she didn't want her real
name used she said you can publish my
case but please just give me a suit on
him so he just calls her Julia so this
is Julia demon-possession case now
interestingly enough the guy at the
center of this as I said is this guy
named Richard Gallagher now Richard II
Gallagher is a board-certified
psychiatrist
graduated from both Princeton University
and the Yale University School of
Medicine so this is no quack this is no
you know paranormal I got my degree
online this is nothing nothing like that
okay this is like an actual legit doctor
of psychiatry now it should be noted
however that dr. Gallagher is and was
raised a practicing Catholic and is at
least open to the possibility that
demons could be real although he says if
they are real and he's careful to use
that signifier then them possessing
people is an exceptionally exceptionally
rare case
he's like 99 times out of 100 somebody
comes to you and says they're possessed
by a demon it's simply a mental illness
but he does leave open the possibility
that demons can't possess people and the
case of Julia is one case that he has
very openly championed as being the only
case that he knows of a genuinely
possessed person all right all right so
now Julia like I said no one knows her
real name all they know about her is
that she's an American woman she was
middle aged in 2008 when she approached
the Catholic Church for helps claiming
that she was demonically possessed now
as I said she actually approached them
herself she said that she had been
brought up a Catholic but that in later
years maybe in her teenage years I don't
know they don't really specify that she
had gotten interested in Satanism and so
kind of became involved in a satanic
cult or satanic belief system or
whatever
now Gallagher says that when she first
showed up or when he first met her she
had the whole regalia man she had like
the black robes and all the I she know
she looked like a goth pretty much
at least that's how I'm interpreting his
description of her now
he has actually gone recognized I've
watched like a couple interviews with
this guy he doesn't seem like a crazy
person um you know he could very well be
but I don't really know he seemed like a
normal rational intelligent person to me
so he said that when he first met her
the fact that she came forward and said
yes I've been involved in Satanism for
many years and I think that might be the
reason that I'm now suffering from these
you know symptoms which I think may be
demonic possession you know so she was
initially reluctant to approach the
Catholic Church because she felt kind of
like ambivalent about it but it was
getting to a point where it was like
unlivable and so she felt she needed
help now interestingly as I said when
she first came and said oh I've been
involved in a satanic cult Gallagher
Gallagher was like yes like it because
that seems like you know I mean that
something you did that's like something
that so many people would say and you
see all these [ __ ] like even on we've
done like jojo's on about a haunting and
stuff like that where you know the the
minute like somebody gets demonically
possessed oh they used a Ouija board or
were they Richardson Satanism Rosie's
all very spirited she seems like a very
stereotypical narrative so when she came
to actually she was like almost like a
Hollywood narrative that's exactly
Indian burial ground like that like that
yeah so and I'm not saying that there
aren't people that did like Satan [ __ ]
and there but but I feel like the
percentage is like really really spelt
like who [ __ ] did you know anybody who
did that no I didn't either
no the only when I was growing up well
in the summers in Mississippi there was
nobody involved in any kind of Satanism
there you'd get killed and missus if you
were involved in kind of Satanism now in
Michigan cuz I lived a couple years in
Trenton Michigan if people that know me
the only one dude there that I think
might have been a Satanist was a long
story but this weird mysterious
[ __ ]
oh yeah that guy that guy there in his
little his little pack a misfits
I think he was uh his fake name was
Logan Oh like Wolverine it's be a
toss-up
Logan something or other but we knew who
he really was and I want you to bleep
out what hit real name was I don't want
that in the end okay redact every - okay
his uncle was a cop his uncle thought he
was a fledgling serial killer I never
find dead cats of [ __ ] around up in his
room
oh that reminded me if it's one of those
guys and I can tell you some creepy [ __ ]
about this dude he'd be up there playing
Galaga
7-eleven the middle of the night making
his granddad buckets sit wait in the car
for him it was just a creepy his
granddad could just leave him there
maybe he'd like slap his granddad around
and [ __ ] it was just weird man there was
like a weird story about that guy but we
considered that guy to be a Satanist
back in those days looking back on it I
just think that he was just he was just
a bad dude yeah he's a douche you know
no he wasn't a douche that was the weird
thing about him is that he was very
serious super serious and very kind of
mysterious he didn't act out he was very
much like inward and he had this
girlfriend that was kind of like his
slave maybe and then he had like these
guys that were with him who were also
you know high schoolers who were almost
like worshipers he was almost like a
cult leader that reminds us all we need
to do a show about [ __ ] God Ferrell
and all that he was like that he was
like a rod for those [ __ ] were that
happened in Florida yeah well I worked
for his attorney oh yeah for a while
yeah yep there's a long story not really
a long story but
yeah she wasn't his attorney for very
long though he replaced her with another
attorney but like in the first few
months that was it
I saw his Case Files yeah yeah when I
was working at her office but yeah I'd
like to meet Rob Farrell actually would
you yeah I'd like to go to prison meet
him I'd do an interview with him you
wouldn't I would I wouldn't like to meet
him as like I you know like I'm
starstruck or anything but that would
make an awesome show yeah although I
don't know he doesn't um some serial
killers and stuff like that kind of
facet like their psychology fascinates
me not him so much I know what he is you
know we're Goths
yeah so you know I mean I'm not I'm not
falling for all that you know I mean his
vampire roleplay that's what I mean one
minute see I don't those kind of people
just like annoy me so I feel like I'd
probably just a annoy I wouldn't mind
just going down to interview him talking
about music and then if I can talk about
the crime and yeah see how he's doing in
prison and you know whether or not he
regrets his mistake if he's is he still
a is he still vizago he's tough as I got
the vampire or is he you know that's
another thing that's it because you know
you you probably kind of experience some
of this too but it's like you know I
went to school in the 80s and looking
kind of goth II listening to gothy music
that a lot of people didn't know back
then um you know I got tagged with
Satanist all the time because they
didn't know what a goth was in the
eighties yeah I mean I grew up oh it's
kind of the same thing you know they
just kind of throw [ __ ] at you yeah so I
just think you're walking around a car
to go buy me throw some [ __ ] edge yeah
also by the club you know did you know
it makes slurs yeah it would assume they
would assume your sexual orientation if
you're a guy they assumed that you were
gay everyone just assumed I was a
Satanist or but you know what I mean
it's and also every time I went to the
mall all the you know the the retail
people would follow me around because
it's gonna steal stuff yeah even though
I was like the nerdiest like little
goody two-shoes ever I didn't even like
start smoking and drink until I was like
in my late 20s maybe it's like when I
was a teenager I didn't like nothing bad
when I was in high schools mostly you
know I'm into metal and then I started
to get into goth God didn't really when
I was in high school really didn't have
that much of a look it wasn't solidified
then I ended up in the army pretty quick
so you know I really couldn't do
anything cuz I was gone you know all the
time yeah then I come back to Boston you
know to get back into the scene and
basically I'm Dave a nyan for a few
years until that's a member nineties god
well yeah yeah it just kind of evolved
you know but we gotta get back to the
[ __ ] scene where I'll talk about Gough
we're talking about we're talking about
yeah yeah we're time I say and we're
talking about how this girl this woman
Julia she initially came to the Catholic
Church and said she'd been into Satanism
and that she thought she was possessed
by a demon and it was getting to the
point where she couldn't really handle
it anymore
so she needed their help even though she
was kind of like ambivalent about it now
the Roman Catholic Church as you've
probably seen in many movies and stuff
like that they don't initially jump to
demon possession which you know to their
credit you know amid all the other
things that they can be accused of they
don't usually jump right to that they
usually try to like you know get rid of
all the other possibilities before they
go to demon possession even then it's
like really super hard to like get an
exorcism so one of the first things they
did like after this woman approached
them was they went to dr. Richard
Gallagher who was kind of their go-to
guy cuz he was like a psychiatrist and
he'd been to like he had all these like
advanced degrees and stuff but he was
still a practice practicing Catholic so
he was one of the ones they went to to
say hey this is this person just nuts or
is there something here that we need to
investigate or whatever now he says that
when he first met her again she had like
the whole goth thing going on so that
kind of made him skeptical at first too
because he said oh this seems like very
stereotypical but then he said that she
one of the things she did was that she
do like people's secrets like in the
room she had like some weird like
psychic ability kind of [ __ ] going on
which kind of freaked him out yeah what
do they call that they call that cryptic
knowledge no what do they call it it's
an ability sometimes that so-called
possessed people might have yeah I think
it's a part of a person being a
poltergeist agent though really part of
yeah but I forgot the yeah I can't put
the word I know what you're talking
about but I can't remember the word
either arcane knowledge no fact what's
the term anyway
yeah it's knowing something that you
have no way of knowing like a good
example is some poltergeist agents have
reportedly had the ability to tell you
how much money it was in your pocket or
where you had just come from yeah you
just talked to they in the Enfield
poltergeist evidently that's that's the
way it was with Janet Janet could answer
questions about another person she had
no way of knowing yeah that seemed to be
the case with this chick also she seemed
to know things about and she had
supposedly never met any of these people
before but she supposedly knew like
their family members names like if their
family members had died what they had
died of what they had been doing like
the day before you know what clues they
had been wearing she supposedly knew
that kind of stuff now interestingly one
of the first things and I think when I
was researching my book um there was a
couple different sources on this one of
the couple of the sources said that she
knew this thing about like all this
stuff that had happened with these cats
like freaking out in someone's house and
the sources that I saw attributed it to
someone that was just kind of there at
the time but then the other day I was
watching an interview with richard
gallagher himself and he said the first
time I met Julia the first thing she
said to me was something like those cats
really went crazy last night didn't they
that was like the first thing she said
and he said you know I have two cats in
about two three in the morning for
whatever reason
you know they started fighting and like
freaking out and they never done that
before and it woke me and my wife up and
we thought it was very weird
so he's like so I just come in and meet
this woman that I'd never met before and
that was the first thing she said to me
was that wow those cats really freaked
out less or those cats really like went
batshit or something like that she said
something like that to him so he thought
that was really creepy like I said it
was I thought it was weird that like a
couple sources said that it was like
somebody else but then I saw with dr.
Gallagher he said you know that was me
deer in my episode I didn't have I
didn't really have that ability or if
that's what you want to call it or that
phenomenon did not appear yeah but what
I kind of imagined maybe it's kind of
situation where the the agent is
actually reading the memories are
somehow sensing the memories of the
target that's what is going on and it
just kind of comes to them you know
they're not doing it on purpose they
just see it in a vision yeah and they
make a comment about it that's probably
how that goes down it yeah very well
maybe and you know a Stuart Hameroff and
said it have to do with like quantum
consciousness yeah that's how he would
say that's how he would explain it which
what Stuart Hameroff says you know I
give a lot of credence to that it checks
out with my observations yeah yeah but
so yes so that whole thing happened so
then dr. Gallagher is kind of like
giving her the standard you know kind of
psychiatric rundown and like seeing if
there's anything um you know
particularly you know any red flags or
anything like that now he says that she
seemed like a very well-adjusted very
intelligent woman she didn't seem to
have any mental instability of any kind
or any mental illness of any kind
um you know so she she didn't really
seem to have anything wrong with her so
he started to think well maybe there's
something to this
so he tells that to the church they all
kind of like you know get together and
have meetings with her and things like
that because like I said this this
demonic possession that she said that
she had was apparently starting to cause
her a great deal of
you know distress and she really wanted
something done about it so they were all
trying to help her out
now during some of the sessions that
they had with her which usually included
dr. Gallagher would be there there'd be
like a bunch of different clergy there
sometimes there would be like students
and things that were like volunteers
that kind of came to observe and whatnot
so a lot of people were witnesses to
this type of stuff um they said that she
would go into trances that she would
usually talk in different voices just
like in the exercise she could talk and
like other people's voices and stuff
that weren't like hers one of them was
like a very very deep like a man's voice
one of them was like a really
high-pitched voice they said when she
went into the trances like when she was
like in her normal like day-to-day
whatever um she was just very like I
said she seemed very intelligent very
even-keeled
you know nothing weird about her at all
but when she went into these specific
trances they said she would get very
combative she would get very you know
she would start spewing profanities she
would start you know going on the whole
anti-religious shtick like I said it's
just like an exorcist where she was just
like you know in a certain way though
like Enfield poltergeist and like yeah
and I'm told you guys it's that it's
this is already something like that same
phenomenon it definitely does and like I
said you know I wrote a whole book
called unseen hands it's all about
different poltergeist for them and
there's like a an amazing amount of
similarity molarity is between a lot of
the manifestations like from case to
case whether it's demonic whether it's
considered demonic possession or not
it's psychic I'm telling you I was there
associate its psychic it's not demonic
yeah if it is a real phenomenon I think
it's all it is a real thing I think it's
all the same thing she's always
forgetting it's a real phenomenon you
only got a little taste of it had you
lived that [ __ ] for a couple weeks on
end you go yeah it says real I'm just
saying that you saw a couple of things
jump off here there that you know
[ __ ] if you get a real strong young
poltergeist agent you know 12 13 14
maybe early 20s with the right emotional
situation you know going on that should
Olympia it doesn't last long though yeah
a couple weeks then it's gone yeah no uh
Janet was the longest one she was what
18 months I think it was about a year
and a half yeah now I learned about some
that went on for years and years but
that's very very yeah it normally just
kind of burns out you know the although
the weird thing about this woman is that
I mean I don't know how old she was when
she first contacted the Roman Catholic
Church about wanting an exorcism but
they did say she was middle-aged quote
unquote so I'm guessing she was in her
40s maybe yeah
which that doesn't strange here doesn't
yeah that's unusual but there doesn't
seem to be an age limit I mean I was in
my 40s when you saw that's more than you
saw and I read about a couple of cases
where it was like older women just yeah
yeah it's just tends not to be as strong
although that a one older woman you're
talking with more little gold flakes
that would appear on things and you know
but I think she was just kind of usually
pent up and it's always kind of a
repressive culture where they come from
it or a kind of a repressed situation
it's you know emotion has a lot to do
with yeah I feel like it's people that
have to like tamp down their emotions
yeah so they're sort of like leaking out
yeah they're acting like a Jiffy Pop
yeah they're acting out well I don't
want to use the word but I've got to use
the word they're acting out psychically
as so it can be deniable so they won't
be blamed for it
ya know like it's not me it's just like
it's the Deemer doing it some evil force
like moving [ __ ] around viewings of
people and scratching them and stuff the
only one do exception I would think is
the Rain Man yeah I mean he knew it was
him basically he knew that he had power
he had the power to do it but he also
thought that there was demonic forces
involved and as far as I know he still
believes that yeah I think that he
thought that something
was like inside of him that was doing it
oh good boo-boo the camera baby cookie
she doing man no stop it she's yeah
she's like what is the game I had it the
way I wanted it she's like what she's
kicking out for buying my laptop okey
come here c'mere baby come here Pookie
be on the show we're pulling that was
another that was another comment that I
got that apparently when people are just
listening to the show and doing other
things as soon as we say as soon as we
say hey here's the kitty they come
running back in so they can see her
there she is
okay there's little pokey pokies not
possessed by a demon or any baby I don't
think did she scratch you yeah she's mad
she want to be picked up she's like know
who I was I'm pushing the camera around
okay get back to this young all right so
yeah so she would go into these trans
states she would start doing like The
Exorcist [ __ ] about you know you know
saying all kind of like profane things
about religion and like [ __ ] on
religion as concept and I guess and
whatnot and saying things about people
in the room and when she woke up
quote-unquote from these trans states
she would say that she had no memory of
them now in most situations and in cases
where there is no other manifestation
present ie things moving around on their
own things of that nature someone who
just displayed this type of behavior
would usually be diagnosed with some
sort of dissociative disorder and dr.
Gallagher has said that in ninety nine
times out of a hundred you come somebody
comes to you like presenting these types
of you know behaviors then that is what
you would that's basically what you
would say that they had they had some
kind of dissociative disorder if there
was no other thing but like no other
unexplainable thing manifestations going
on I've mentioned it earlier I think
poltergeist comes from poultra to the
poltergeist phenomenon
as I know it comes from a situation that
really doesn't exist anymore
yeah because social media and
interconnectivity well people have a lot
more opportunity to vent to vent
knowledge and to find people with
similar interests or similar um you know
I I don't want to say like similar
mental illnesses or so you know that
type of things they convinced because
they can find people in similar
situations
yeah it doesn't talk yeah and they can
communicate with others which kind of
helps release pressure yeah because you
know you're not alone other people feel
the same way as you it's like you can
talk to other people about it you're
gonna find they can relate to you if
you're gonna find this phenomenon today
you're gonna find it in a place that's
gonna be some kind of picked up
religious community maybe some Amish
people maybe some Mormons when these
Mormon cults I was gonna say if anybody
Amish is living right now that I'm like
oh yeah you wouldn't maybe somebody in
the Middle East or in Africa where
there's a religiosity but not really
interconnectivity you're gonna find it
there although it does exist in the
modern era too because remember the girl
that from from from paranormal witness
that I talked to the one from the cat
episode from very yeah yeah I'm friends
with her on Facebook I talked to her for
hours you know I can't remember her name
off we believe that it was her
stepsister that was doing it yeah and
that was in the modern era she caught
some of it on her cell phone yeah she
even sent me some recorded messages from
her cell phone when she shared them when
you have them she gave me permission to
share it
yeah of the damn poltergeist leaving the
message and it was [ __ ] creepy we
never got her you yeah that was pretty
creepy
but I was never I haven't shared it yet
because she didn't come on the show she
talked about coming on the show we
should never got around to her about it
but we never got around to it and I was
gonna save it for that because that was
a really good episode yeah she has she
has a clip that came on her
Kame is a voice message from I can't
remember what the address she said he
came from he came from basically nowhere
yeah it was just on her phone like an
unknown message yeah and it's just kind
of a weird electrical sound one yeah
like that and then you hear like a what
sounds like a voice good yeah so like
chitty chitty chitty chitty chitty and
it makes it makes sense in in relation
to the case because they got the
poltergeist on this cat kick dude threw
the cat out ramit cats ram and then from
there on out it started writing cat on
the wall over and over and over and they
found all these little scribbles of the
word cat everywhere and then she got a
message on her cell phone and it was 50
k key they sound like kitty kitty kitty
yeah yeah so post guys to be pretty
[ __ ] weird I've heard it's kind of a
it's a mindless phenomenon that comes
from the subconscious and it's the
subconscious the thing that makes dreams
and dream characters and your dreams
come to life well imagine that thing
acting out using using telekinesis and
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about poltergeists and demons
yeah yeah it's a part of you it's the
thing in your dreams that attacks you
when you're fighting yeah you another
version of you yeah yeah that's what it
is that's like I said that's kind of
that's kind of where I'm coming from and
I'm coming here to yeah because in every
case it in a way Oh bleep a response to
the wishes of the damn poltergeist agent
it always certain you would serve in
your best interest that's why when I
wrote unseen hand I said I'm gonna put a
whole chapter in here about demonic
possession because I really think that
demonic possession is probably just the
same type of like poltergeist or
psychokinetic phenomenon just
interpreted through a religious or a
particularly Catholic Lynn well the guy
that was there on that first on that on
that
exorcism that The Exorcist was based off
yeah he was he wasn't The Exorcist
himself he was a guy help him yeah he
wrote a whole book about it he said no
as poltergeist phenomenon it was psychic
indeed it sounded like he saw it happen
in name when he when he read more about
it and he got into the parapsychological
it materially goes yeah that's what it
was I mean the kid was like not a man
around like he would make chairs by
around he was sitting in them like they
would push against the wall and not a
demon it's not a demon as described in
the Old Testament words on his skin a
real demon would [ __ ] wipe out a city
see that's it all right that's what
bothers men it's like why why what a
demon of all things right
waste their time messing around the soul
possessing a twelve year old kid in them
nowhere why would they do that a demon
as described in a religious literature
wipes out [ __ ] like whole cities right
what causes cities of people pray come
sinful weird [ __ ] like that like you
know but yeah they can do like superhero
supervillain supervillain [ __ ] yeah and
be super villains yeah they don't mess
around Rijn they don't why would they
possess one person yeah and make one
person throw up and jerk off with a
crucifix why like yeah they're not into
that they had a hard time explaining
that in the movie Exorcist yeah of why
it was had that but power of Christ
compels you I never get tired it's good
movie
that's like it's like in my top five
it's like that The Shining there's a
couple other movies that I can just
watch over and over again I just never
get tired of it Oh max was von Sydow in
the [ __ ] out of that really yes he was
do you know he was in a whole bunch of
like he was old back when he was young
well he was in a bunch of like Ingmar
Bergman movies like back in the day yeah
I totally want to do a review if I know
I know you don't really like like art
movies and stuff but I totally want to
do a review of our of the wolf one of
these days
David Lynch was totally influenced by
that [ __ ] okay that was like a creepy I
think it was like the this like pretty
much the closest thing to a horror movie
to Ingmar Bergman Bergman ever did I'm
gonna creep
and he and Max von Sydow was in that to
end up on a death in Rome video probably
well at some point there's some really
like creepy disturbing imagery in that
so since we were talking about phones
cuz we were talking about the the kiddie
poltergeist there one of the things that
kind of interested me about this Julia
case was this phone [ __ ] that she would
do so now what dr. Gallagher said was
that occasionally him and the other
people that were consulting on the case
which like priests nuns like I said
there were other students there that
were observing and stuff and they would
like call each other and like talk about
the case now several of them said that
while they were having discussions about
the case on the phone another voice
would break in on the phone call that
was supposedly Jul sometime - it was
Julia's voice or sometimes it was one of
the other voices that she would do and
her voice would come on and say [ __ ]
like leave her alone you idiot she's
ours leave you imbecile priest things
like that so they would get like these
phone calls this was like after hours
they weren't around her at the time they
were just like at their houses and they
were calling each other you know talking
about the case and it could have been
her head was their present well even
that or she was like in the hospital
wherever the hell they were keeping her
so she didn't have access to a phone
well and the thing is it's like how
would she be able to break into a phone
call between two two other ways that's
what I'm saying they'd be talking to
each other like from their respective
houses she wouldn't even ah all of a
sudden her voice would like turn up on
the call and everybody's like what the
[ __ ] I thought you meant that they were
talking to her that's a yeah that would
just be normal this was like way weirder
because they're like yeah we didn't do
like three-way call this was like you
know they weren't doing like 3-way
calling or nothing she was just like
break-in on the [ __ ] line with one of
her weird voices and have these like
quote-unquote demonic voices sings oh
she's ours and you can't have her and
all this other kind of stuff just like
an X just as like I said um another
thing that she could do like I said she
had psychic ability
she told dr. Gallagher that his mom had
died of ovarian cancer which was true so
that kind of freaked him out a little
bit um she also as I said she could tell
what like people were doing like when
when they weren't there like she's like
oh this person's doing this that and the
other like right now and then later on
they would find out that that was
correct she would do kind of [ __ ] like
you know that you just her standard
Exorcist iperceptions like like animal
sounds she could talk in Latin and in
Spanish which apparently neither
language of which she knew because I
guess she said English was the only
language that she spoke but she could
speak recognizable Spanish and
recognizable Latin you know [ __ ] like
that um also another thing that they
thought was interesting was that and I
like that they do this test because they
said one of the things that makes it so
that they will actually say that maybe
it's an actual demon possession is
they'll do a test where they'll sprinkle
holy water on you or they'll sprinkle
tap water on you you gotta and if you
flip out like to the tap water like it
burns like in The Exorcist then they
think you're faking but if you can tell
the difference without them saying then
that's like another point in your favor
and apparently she was able to do that
because they would you know hit her with
tap water and she wouldn't do anything
but they would hit her with actual holy
water that have been blessed by a priest
and all that rigmarole and she would
know the difference she'd be like I
burned all of us as she would do that
kind of stuff now apparently there were
also a bunch of physical like kind of
psychokinetic kind of [ __ ] going on as
well
walsh's was in addiction yeah you know
where stuff would like fly off the
shelves well she was around much like in
the you know the Ravi Mannheim case that
The Exorcist was based on now some of
the witnesses said that she levitated
off the bed although I read an I read an
interview with dr. Gallagher that was in
The Washington Post I think and he
didn't
should not so I don't know if that was
like a later edition or if it just
happened when he wasn't there like he
never witnessed that personally yeah now
so many people out think about there
might be a man [ __ ] how can a person
do psychokinesis happily they throw some
without without grabbing it and throwing
it you know the doing it with your mind
that's that's [ __ ] I understand that
reaction what the theory is even from oh
[ __ ] what was the guy's name I mean
haven't been I'm in the Drake
Stuart Hameroff who any could do it you
know who he's you know he said he's
hanging out with you know Sir Roger
Penrose and stuff these guys are you
know real scientists physicists you know
and he said he starts talking about
Schrodinger's cat and Jenny can pry it
explains sure there's cat better than me
it's you know what is reality you know
you put a cat in a box how do you know
the status of the cat until you open the
box you know is the cat alive or dead
really you don't find out until the box
is open then you collapse the wig and
you collapse the wave function well what
we're talking about basically you know
I'm gonna give you a [ __ ] version
of this okay is that reality really has
a lot to do with your perception okay
and your awareness of things this is
actually can be proven that like this
quantum and a subatomic level subatomic
particles know when you're looking at
them or not Jenica priox planet and
they're to me that you're smarter than
me do you really understand that how
something could well no wonder state
with a complete okay if you say that you
understand quantum physics you're
[ __ ] lie nobody I think there's like
a couple people it may be maybe it's not
our brains did not evolve because it
wasn't necessary yeah our brains did not
evolve to reality is not as weakly is
that yeah yeah we're only perceiving a
certain part of reality reality is a lot
bigger than our little monkey like
abilities
see ya what we're talking about as a
person who's because of some kind of
mental state or emotional state their
perception is so distorted that it
actually distorts reality itself that
probably a good way appointment that is
a good way for it means you're tripping
so badly that reality is [ __ ]
responding to your trip yeah that'd
probably be a good simple way to explain
and here's the weird thing it's not
happening by force there's no force
required to do it because this is
happening outside of our understanding
of what energy and force actually is it
has to do it like the perception of
reality your perception of the reality
is so distorted because you're in this
mental state that other people actually
see the distortions that you're causing
yeah that's probably like a label in in
the large majority of situations I think
most people's perceptions are more or
less accurate because they would have to
be I mean if if our perceptions of
reality were not accurate our species
would have died out a long time ago but
the thing about it is that there's so
much weird [ __ ] that we don't understand
and there might be some situations and
they're probably very rare where like
you said you know someone's perception
of reality is affecting other people's
perception of reality like around them
now here's a weird thing if a person can
do this without any energy and any
technology then that means there may be
a possibility if you have enough
technology enough energy you can do it
yeah so that's a weird [ __ ] console
so one thing that we kind of taught and
we talked about this a lot I think that
it almost seems like an if in pretty
much every case other than maybe one or
two that I've researched the person
could not do it on command you can only
do it when you think it's not you
exactly that's that that check you have
to allow it
rather than Terrell it but here's the
weird thing
you might be able to build a technology
around this sure if there are aliens
coming here and evidently recently there
are people that are involved in the
government and government contract who
says yeah we're our pilots are seeing
weird things if aliens were to ever come
here to be witnessed they're probably
using a technology based upon this
concept basically they're you'd be able
to fold space by doing this because some
of the stuff that I saw some of the
phenomenons that I saw with things
basically teleporting okay
and not only moving without any energy
but [ __ ] vanishing reappearing
somewhere else where they could
instigate instantaneously and they
couldn't have gotten there without going
through you know walls or something well
that's kind of like what Frank Hubert's
talking about dune with the guild
steersman taking it right well um you
know if there's aliens coming here
they're probably using something like
that a machine that can do that yeah
yeah maybe I hope maybe we she intimated
their minds be probably if the mind can
do it a machine can do it too that's the
way yeah right we're tripping myself out
I know right his mind I can see his
little mind go yeah yeah whatever powers
UFOs is probably some kind of the same
thing that powers a poltergeist if we
ever figure it out they'll figure that
aliens will just be like about time yeah
it's like why did it take you guys like
seven thousand years of space time is
not real if you look at from this
imagine it's like they're looking at it
from a higher dimension aliens are gonna
be like yes like yeah you're worried
about going this be going you know right
left up and down in Newark South now you
go out you go out of it and then you pop
back in it's easy yeah they're like duh
if you were two dimensional and you're
talking to a three dimensional person
you'd see it as like flat land you like
where's this voice coming from because
there's no concept of her up or down
well there's school there's hyper nice
uh actually Carl Sagan talked about it
on cosmos I know but I read it in school
okay
when I was little yeah I saw a whole
cosmos series and I was a little kid I
grew up on that [ __ ] yeah
yeah that music wha-wha-wha Vangelis and
[ __ ] with that Vangelis doing I think it
wasn't that usually cosmos passed me to
Germany dude sure he did Chariots of
Fire - sure it's fine
yeah it was like something you can smoke
weed and listen to [ __ ] carsick
that's true of anything yeah but yeah I
mean Carl Sagan was a sexy [ __ ]
back in the day he was oh yeah I
understand it I understand see I'm in
love that dude well there's something
that there's something super foxy about
that's why Neil deGrasse Tyson and
severe sizzling there's something very
sexy about a dude that's that that knows
all things [ __ ] and he knows all that
[ __ ] yeah you know what I mean
different what Tyson is that Tyson
wasn't a wimp
Tyson was a wrestler he beat you up -
yeah yeah he's a big dude yeah say he's
kind of full spectrum I was just gonna
say I was reading an article - about
Richard Fineman who was like a very
famous physically day and he was a [ __ ]
man that's like he was like he was a
pickup artist before there were pickup
artists you know and I mean he was doing
all that should see Tyson special gifts
gift was that he knows how to
communicate I mean that guy can just
deliver lines and he's got it he's got I
read all his buddies personality you
know I mean I mean he's not funny he's
not the nerdiest guy you know I think
that the nerdy guys actually do a lot of
a really hard [ __ ] there but they do
yeah they're so socially awkward you
can't put them in front of well the
thing about it - a dyson out there and
you go yeah science the [ __ ] out of this
the thing about it and it's sad because
people that are like really really
really super intelligent
it's very rare for a person like that to
also have like really good social skills
it's two things that don't usually go
together sometimes they do but that's a
very rare individual it's it's two
completely different right it's two
completely different like mental states
to different personality types and I
think genetically just those two things
are not they just very very rarely go
together yeah so I think that's why it's
so rare like you know when you get a
carl sagan you get a Neil deGrasse Tyson
you get somebody that is super super
intelligent but can also communicate
and is yes socially adept yeah I mean
cuz that's why it's such a big deal
because it doesn't happen that often
I'm basically a knucklehead III really
don't like nerds you know I mean it that
way I just you know nerds yeah you know
I mean when I was in Boston I was around
the Ivy League you know students all the
time I'd see them at the club got some
MIT and good [ __ ] nerds man you know
you don't want to be around them it's
it's almost like a disease yeah but
Tyson I could hang with Tyson I'm a
problem addict and [ __ ]
well it depends yeah probably no you
know I ran into nerds it back in the day
headaches head experiments on the damn
space show yeah yeah I told you that
story yeah man I couldn't stand to be
rather dude some of them are Jeremy ran
that dude he just just yeah never seen
Revenge of the Nerds the nerdiest dude
it off of friends with the Nerds
it was [ __ ] four times worse than
that I was embarrassed to be around dude
I start getting it started getting like
shy [ __ ] like that I can't it was almost
like Arizona's right it's almost like
autism well that was Prague out that
same pizza place all time the same pizza
please say you went to yeah I'd go to
there he'd be in here all the time want
to hang out [ __ ] I gotta go although I
have to say like I said and I mentioned
this on the show before it's like I'm I
can do alright but I'm I find hey I'm
very introverted and I find hanging out
with people very tiresome you know what
I mean especially people that are very
boisterous and stuff [ __ ] lie no I'm
just saying it's like internet club
she's like a social butterfly
well yeah but I know those people yeah
okay all right if I have to like talk in
front of people I don't know or anything
I mean I know those people like I can
talk to those people that's cool like
you know what I mean but it's like if I
have to like hang out with people I
don't know or we look we gonna approach
people I don't know [ __ ] that we went to
a Horicon and she was centered attention
she that the horican and I hated it
wait like he would go like we would go
to like what the [ __ ] it called screen
faster whatever no no speaking apart
spooky empire they used to be called
scream fest yeah but he would go and
like I would make him it's like I'm like
go like make people buy my book I'm just
gonna sit here and be quiet because I'm
not I'm not good at like cold
approaching I'll sell every book she
brought he did yeah the first night like
Friday night he sold them all so now I
got put on panels and I could do that
even though I was like super nervous
beforehand and I needed to drink before
I went up there because other than that
I I just get like really really nervous
and I worry that I'm gonna say something
Dom and I still worry about that when
we're recording the show even though I
could make it out if I wanted no ever do
yeah but yeah so alright so let's get
back to talking about Julia so like I
said some people said she levitated they
were jump right back in this [ __ ]
levitated yeah what did I miss did I
miss something you did miss it because I
mentioned it a long time ago okay I bust
it see how you go you just go off on
these no I'm [ __ ] drink then you
forget look I'm starting to bang on all
cylinders so my net [ __ ] here is strong
how long we've been talking I don't know
how much I bet is that two hours right
there eleven minutes our limits all the
time we gotta [ __ ] rebel break it we
gotta wrap up the first yeah we got to
get to the face eating holy crap yeah
this is a good part of shows yes so some
people said that she levitated off the
bed like I said just like Reagan did in
The Exorcist um
Gallagher not say what he didn't really
mention it um also said she had like the
whole superhuman strength thing going on
like six people would try to restrain
her and they couldn't so um evidently
the Catholic Church came to the
conclusion yes she is demonically
possessed so we need to do something
about that so they decided to do like
some major rites of exorcism like they
do now some sources that I read said
they did two exorcism some said they did
as many as eight I'm not sure which one
is correct
um but during these exorcisms same kind
of [ __ ] happen she's like you know
spewing blasphemous whatnot and like
saying all kind of you know [ __ ] to the
the priests that were attending her that
like somehow how could she know that and
I was funny because we watched The
Exorcist the other day and I was how
understated that movie is by today's
standards it was very effective back in
the day it was just [ __ ] eerie well
yes some creepy give us some little [ __ ]
yeah because you can kind of creepy the
creepiest scene in that I mean aside
from the whole crab-walk thing that
wasn't even in like that wasn't in the
normal cut release that was like in the
director's cut later on the creepiest
scene in that to me is when Karras has
the dream about his mom coming up the
subway steps and then turning around
again and when he comes in the room and
sees instead of Reagan he sees his mom
sitting on the bed in like this
spotlight type said that maybe that was
to me that was the creepiest scene I
don't know why [ __ ] like that creeps me
out I don't know why D me why you do the
yeah when she started talking like in
that woman you're not my mother
whatever this is and I don't know why
this is like maybe somebody that has
like some kind of psychology background
can life let me know why the [ __ ] this
freaks me out so much
something that freaks me out in movies
one what people when people are in two
places at once that's why David Lynch
movies freak me out so much because he
does that kind of [ __ ] a lot and also
when somebody starts talking in a
different voice that's why the that's
why the whole [ __ ] with um Danny in the
shining when he starts going Brad that's
why that freaks me out too but the first
time I saw that I was like haha know
that I don't know why that bothers me it
just bothers me so once and that scene
in the others were like she comes around
it's like an old lady it starts talking
in her daughter's voice oh that freaked
me out so bad I don't know why but yeah
so so that when when Reagan and the
extra sister is talking and her mom's
voice and stuff and talking he talks in
[ __ ] Burke's voice - yeah do you know
what she did
freak me out too I was like oh that's
that guy she threw out the window
spoiler alert that's a masterpiece movie
and I think it's lost on young people
today because they're just so
desensitized you know what some of these
second over-the-top horror movies but
there was just the kind of the subtlety
of all little yeah several movies freak
me out one day more it kind of affects
us because I guess we the nostalgia
factor probably also well and stuff
that's over the top I think the problem
with that is that the more you show like
this gross like gory [ __ ] it's like I
like watching that but it just makes me
laugh back in the day you cuz it's just
over-the-top and funny and then you have
to put yourself back in the day back in
the day world watching this movie and
it's being presented as a film yeah yeah
I mean this isn't a flick this is a
[ __ ] with a capital F well yeah as if
it's real yeah there's a certain that
this really happened so there's some
kind of formal about it
you know man like yeah so little things
that would happen in it had a greater
impact because you're taking the movie
seriously almost kind of like it's a
documentary we say when I was a kid I
looked almost exactly like Linda Blair
so like yeah so yeah so like when I saw
that movie and like even later on cuz my
mom was like god that looks just like
you and I was like that's kind of yeah
she looks just like that yeah so anyway
all right so they do they're doing the
exorcisms on Julia she does the standard
exorcism kind of stuff there's like [ __ ]
flying around all this kind of stuff all
these like weird voices coming out of
her now some of the witnesses said that
while they were doing this stuff it was
really really hot outside I think it was
June when they were doing it but the the
room got like super super cold just like
an extras that happened in that movie
too but also there was another time to
you where the room got so hot that
everyone had to leave like it was just
like a [ __ ] heater in there now dr.
Gallagher said that however many
exorcisms they did whether it was 2 8
whatever that they did actually kind of
help but that she was still showing
symptoms of
this kind of demon possession or having
whatever it was it she was now at some
stage Julia herself came to a point
where she's like I don't really want to
continue with this even though they
weren't really done with the exorcism
because I guess you know it takes more
than one or whatever um like I said she
she was very ambivalent about
approaching the church in the first
place
so I guess that you know after they'd
done a couple of these rites she's like
[ __ ] this I'm not doing this anymore or
maybe it doesn't bother me
um I think Gallagher later said that she
said something to him to the effect that
I kind of liked the power that I get
from the demon and maybe I don't want
him to leave so I don't know if that was
a factor also so she basically just
[ __ ] off and um I believe Gallagher
didn't have any contact with her until a
little bit later they said the last time
that he heard from her she told them
that she had cancer I don't know how
much longer is how much later this was
then like after they had done the
exorcisms but she had cancer and she was
kind of thinking about oh maybe I'll
come back and finish the whole exorcism
thing but then she never came back and
he never heard from her again and he was
kind of upset about it so I guess she
decided that she liked having the demon
so she just ran off with the demon so
she just ran off with it cuz like I said
I guess they weren't it like they didn't
however many they did I from what I
heard like I said some sources said Oh
as many as eight but I think that's an
exaggeration what I heard was that they
did one and completed it and then it
wasn't quite right I guess and so they
said we'll do another one and they only
get about halfway through the second one
and then she was like I don't want to do
it anymore and she took off that's what
I heard
so I don't know how she turned out like
I said I don't know what her real name
was nobody knows except for him
presumably so I don't know if she still
got the demon and she's still running
around out there somewhere what was that
movie that we watched the other day that
was about oh it was so funny I think it
was on Netflix or shudder I can't
remember but it was about
like a it was like Alcoholics Anonymous
but it was for people that had been
possessed by demons it was called Ava's
something
Ava's exorcism or something like that it
was really funny it was like a horror
comedy and it was like a concept I'd
never seen before but it kind of
reminded me of this because one of the
women in the in the support group was
just like no I like the demon I want to
keep it or I want to get it back you
know what I mean it sounds like a
culture guys
yeah it definitely doesn't sound like
that it sounds like the girl ran off and
kind of result resolved the poltergeist
situation on her own it burns out after
after so which maybe that's what
happened right how long did this go on
for oh I don't know okay
it probably just resolved itself it
seemed like it wasn't a huge amount of
time I mean from the way he's talking
about it yeah so you know I don't know
it's not know dates are given so we
don't know like I said it happened in
2008 as far as an hour that's when she
first like approached the church about
it and they started doing the X well
she's out there she can [ __ ] give us
a call like they have wrong yeah I'm
kind of like curious about what was
happening with it because I mean the
fact that you got an actual like certain
board-certified psychiatrist who have
made a like Yale and [ __ ] to like come
and go I was there he's possessed by
demons I was there you know a big deal I
had I had a similar thing happened to me
man I was there so you know I can speak
your language yeah I'm kind of curious
apologize all right all right so let's
take a break right now and when we come
back from the break what you've all been
waiting for we're talking about the face
eating wasn't really eating that was
face tearing don't spoil it well you
already okay oh and there's much worse
but yeah weird - the dog - yeah just
that just a trigger warning it's like if
you're if you're really efficient about
the animals because I know that feeling
I get like that to you and that's
another thing that I was really mad and
we had we had somebody to comment such
as saying that when there were little
kids assistant they nailed the kitten to
the foot that's what I was just gonna
say I was [ __ ] [ __ ]
behind that this is America December
person later like get back to me on this
did that person later become a serial
killer your your uncle or whatever it
was it was it was their uncle right this
America their mom's brother yeah
does they have an English degree this
was done in England but if that had
happened here [ __ ] I'm making
pay my [ __ ] my my ex-husband's mom
yeah drowned a bunch of kittens in a bag
like yeah you got on the river and I was
like yeah how can I say that was whales
all right yeah and I said this on this
I'm like how I can't even step on a bug
and not feel bad it's like much less
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] how drowning that's
kind of rough man oh how could you do
that in Mississippi I even in
Mississippi I heard of just people just
taking cats and [ __ ] taking it far
away and let them go I mean even that
like cats are you unless they're super
little it's like they they can usually
like take care of themselves and become
feral yeah yeah it's like so I would rat
like why can't them
just when I'm in a box take them far
away it's like you know don't live
somewhere is probably gonna be are
probably in a built-up area Oh Brian a
built-up area very suburban just let him
be stray cats why do you gotta kill him
I don't get it shut it down shut it yeah
all right so we're gonna take a break
right now when we get back we're going
to talk about the case of Michael Taylor
this happened in a little town called
asset in Yorkshire and it's pretty
[ __ ] up so you'll want to say you'll
want to stay tuned through the break
we'll be back in just
[Music]
I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
protect the paper and conclude at the
end of the day at this house and will
continue to be honored there a long time
see that's what that warm laundry does
that's what that warm laundry does to
you huh
would you say about that maybe you like
to be in a laundry you like being a
laundry cover you up I'm gonna cover you
up like that now what now what now well
nothing huh just go sit there what you
can say yeah it's incredible incredible
is it good nice and warm warm laundry
going to sleep go and sleep on the warm
laundry yawning yeah let's just relax a
minute Kraemer thought the same thing
Kramer put that [ __ ] in a damn oven the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century vol
2 includes cases spanning the years from
1960 through 1979 featuring such
infamous crimes as the triple homicide
at Lake Bodom
the family Massacre known as the good
heart murders the serial killings of the
Zodiac Bible John Jack the stripper and
the freeway phantom the slaughter of
dozens of women and girls along the
highway of tears and the Texas killing
fields and the mysterious death of
suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts
by it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format alright we are back
from the break now we're gonna talk
about the face ripping just like we
promised this is also another case of
demon possession which I kind of talked
about in he's called the face ripping
yeah this is a weird weird case yeah
might be some to this and like I said
you know this has been requested a
couple times and you know finally I
decided yeah we'll finally talkable
talked about on the show because I did
write about it my book and it seemed
like it needed yeah I'm just saying now
I think there might be something to both
these cases that first went to me that
sounded like poltergeist yeah I don't
think either these are demon possession
but I think there's two different things
going on in these cases I'm gonna call
it bio paranormal paranormal that comes
from living creatures trademark so this
case here this stems from 1974 this is
the case of michael taylor also known as
the offset exorcist murder now let's set
the scene a little bit so AUSA is this
little bitty town located near the town
of Wakefield in West Yorkshire in
England now at the time it was a fairly
small town I'm guessing just kind of you
know kind of place where it's just very
small town everyone's just kind of like
doing the [ __ ] everyone's going to
church and you would never imagine that
something of this magnitude of the
horror in the never - what is that yeah
this is like the British equivalent of
John Cougar Mellencamp going on I'm
imagining that yeah so if anybody some
jack if you guys lived in the in West
Yorkshire 1974 and clarify please let me
know
so the family that lives in this little
town consists of Michael Taylor who was
31 years old at the time he had a wife
named Christine they had five children
they also had a little dog like every
family did I believe it was a poodle I
think some other sources said it was a
poodle so their neighbors consider them
a completely normal happy completely
normal family there's like nothing weird
going on over theirs there's no violence
no fights no nothing like that it was
just completely normal
a couple their five kids their dog
whatever they said the only thing that
was unusual was that Michael Taylor did
the patriarch I guess you would call it
in the family um he seemed like a very
quiet like mild mannered type of dude
now he had had a back injury at some
stage in the past so he had been I don't
know if he was out of work all this time
but he you know was finding finding it
hard to find like long term work because
you know he had so much trouble with his
back so he had kind of fallen into
depression that kind of came and went
which you know understandable so there
was that whole thing going on but other
than that most of the neighbors said
that was pretty much the only unusual
thing that he had kind of bouts of
depression stemming from his injury now
at this point in time as I said it was
1974 the residents of this town fairly
religious is particularly by English
standards it seems to me most of the
residents of the village like went to
church on Sunday you know like they
would but despite that fact the Taylor
family not so much into the church thing
they did usually didn't go they didn't
really seem to care about it they were
very met on religion religion in general
now after this you know what so this
whole situation is going on now they had
um a friend of the family and her name
was Barbara Wardman and she got it into
her head that maybe
she could kind of help out with Michael
Taylor's depression by kind of getting
him into religion or getting him back
you know coming to church and everything
regularly everyone getting back right
with the Lord
yeah exactly so that was that was her
thinking getting right with the Lord so
she decides that she is going to kind of
introduce him to this church group that
she is a part of now the church group
was called the Christian Fellowship
group and forgive me if this is
offensive but from what I'm reading
about it it seems a little cult II just
just saying it seemed it seemed a little
culty so but this this Barbara person
was like super into it and she thought
that it would help his depression so you
know I guess her intentions were
honorable let's back up for a second all
right we're backing up for a sec all
right you're saying this sounds a little
culty yeah it sounds no speaking in
tongues and I don't know if they were
like handling snakes or drinking
strictness those that extent cult has a
negative connotation it really just
means a little religion really it's a
little religion yeah I know that but I'm
just trying to explain to the audience
really Christianity is a series of a
bunch of little cults it is because
there's so many these little there's
denominations you know you got green
thorak Orthodox you got you got Russian
Orthodox you got Catholic Protestant and
then in the Protestant religion well the
process denomination you got thousands
of little tiny Baptists and all these
little and you can break it on down to
these little private do to yourself
churches 20 30 people you can say that
that's a cult that it's a Christian cult
yeah it's not negative doesn't
necessarily mean that it's bad it's just
you know I mean I'm just trying to make
the audience understand that
Christianity really is a huge group a
little tinier oh yeah that's really what
it is oh I think all major religions
yeah they're all kind of like that
you're right yeah they're all little
cults well because you're all Islam
really there's two different
denominations I mean
you know you got what he called the Shia
you got the Sunni and they also have the
the Sufi okay and there's different
little groups inside this you could say
that's a bunch of different cults too
well to be honest with you with any
human endeavor any human organization of
any kind religious or otherwise you are
never going to get more than let's say
twenty people to agree on yeah so even
if you have a congregation like right of
a thousand people most people are gonna
be like go off in like four or five
directions cuz that's just how humans do
me yeah I mean you got you can't keep
people to agree on this you have an
American version of Christianity like
the thing that busted off a
Protestantism and a totally American
version of this yet Mormonism yeah which
is totally new you know Book of Mormon
yeah I got new scripture is the new
Genesis you know I found these golden
plates in the ground like I don't know
what happened to them they're usually
Rhoni and everything in a glass I can't
show them to you though every every one
of these Damron S&P will say well that's
from hope okay the thing is is that it's
all hokey [ __ ] all day although all the
literature of all these groups you know
God is suspect you know I mean it just
sounds strange to us because you say
well you know Mormon the Mormons that
was eighteen hundreds ago that was just
yesterday yeah I mean that's like well I
think you add another couple thousand
years on initial this is kind of where
the whole like ancient mysteries ancient
aliens and all that kind of stuff comes
from because people tend to think like
the older something is like the more
venerable the more you know the more
legit it is but it's like fuelled back
then we're just dumb [ __ ] just like we
are now go back and listen to dr. price
we had dr. Robert dr. Robert price on
here you know and he that dudes up
[ __ ] a hardcore scholar of all of
these scriptures okay even Islam he
studied that to all these religions kind
of
but I find that I find well I find that
I find it fascinating just because I
find it fascinating how humans their
brains go in particular direction yeah
and so I feel like across different
cultures no matter how far apart the
cultures are they tend to come up with
similar ideas right to explain certain
Austerlitz
it's all a certain genre of literature
it's a religious literature
yeah and it's a certain genre and even
in modern days you have that happening
now with like the Marvel MCU is really
when you look at the bare bones of it
it's religious literature yeah yeah a
couple thousand years from the amount
the MCU is very much like the Greek
pantheon you know very yeah there's
really no different [ __ ] it borrows
from that and you know it's an endless
cycle and if you really trust in the
balance I wasn't any real difference
between the Greek pantheon and the
Canaanite Pantheon that the Old
Testament came from like human brains
tend to all I mean no matter where
you're from no matter where you're born
they all tend to run in similar channels
so you're gonna get similar shits like
showing you so that's our statement
about religion I [ __ ] love religion I
think the shit's interesting do I think
its tree is interesting that is true
there's some truth in it there are some
stories in it and there's some lessons
in it yeah there's there's some true is
it true in the way that the faithful
think it's true
no not maybe no no see you can say well
the Bible what does the Bible say the
Bible says a lot of stuff it says a lot
of things and each one of you got to
take each little thing on its own and
you know my studies of Islam - the three
books that they use the mostly use three
books but yeah it's kind of the same
thing is it true no that's how you look
at it yeah yeah this you know I kind of
built depends on what your definition so
when this group is it's like I said it
had some like culty aspects in in the
context of cults that most people
understand it nowadays were you know
it's like kind of like a Scientology or
a weird type thing
now this particular congregation was led
by a 21 year old woman by the name of
Marie Robinson now even though Michael
Taylor had previously not given a single
whiff of a [ __ ] about religion where
they may give a single whiff of a shot
like a handful of [ __ ] but I don't even
give it like if you if it was over there
and you were smelling it I don't even
give that much of it that's my way with
words
you ought to write books for a living
yeah thanks for recommending yes all
right yeah yeah so he didn't give a [ __ ]
about religion before but suddenly ever
since he gets into this particular
religious group with this 21 year old
pastor who happens to be a female okay I
don't know what she looked like I said
yeah I knew he thought she was hot or
seriously Eric he thought she was hot
when she was like you know objectively
hot or no no is there such a thing
probably not so he starts getting super
into religion suddenly yeah so he goes
to the group he like gets all he gets
all up into it he says yeah I'm speaking
in tongues I'm mom all about it
and
he Ben Murray they start spending a lot
of time together now by most accounts
they were just doing like religious a
[ __ ] like they were like making the sign
of the Cross at each other like I'm well
there was a demons out of you I'm
getting the demons out of you but you
know this is the 21st century everybody
know probably they were [ __ ] yeah but
now deem is that you can put this devil
in you but you know we're all adults
here this all goes back to less there
are children listening which I hope
there or not but this all go back to the
Baker clan and everything you know at
any fee yeah you know they were yeah so
you know I I think they were [ __ ] but
maybe they weren't yeah maybe they
legitimate Lee were thinking they were
like exercising some demons or whatever
okay um but as we will soon find out
that [ __ ]
didn't work out so yeah so they spend
they start spending an awful lot of time
together doing their religious II stuff
exorcising demons and whatnot and other
members of the congregation start to
notice also Michael Taylor's wife
Christine obviously starts to notice too
she's like hey you're spending an awful
lot of time with this 21 year old woman
yeah exorcising demons quote-unquote or
whatever the bucket is demons alright
right yeah so maybe she's getting a
little upset about that understandably
so um also at this stage they said that
his personality started to change he had
previously been pretty laid-back dude
like you know very mild mannered Virgil
nice type of guy um you know kind of
dude you'd always want to hang out with
but at this point after he starts
hanging out with this other chick he
starts getting really irritable he
starts getting kind of crabby it's like
he doesn't really want to spend time
with his family anymore
he just always wants to be you know with
the church group and always doing Church
kind of stuff you know started
exhibiting just a wrap
behavior just kind of like these weird
bizarre beliefs like he was kind of
going off the deep end now during one
meeting because Christine had been I
mean she joined the congregation - they
had both been and and some sources I
read said that she was actually a member
of the congregation first before Michael
Taylor was and then he came into it late
and then got like way more into it than
she was so at one meeting of the
congregation Christine decides that's
the wife in case you had forgotten um
you know she's gonna confront everybody
about this [ __ ] that's been going on
so she pretty much in front of everyone
she pretty much accuses Michael Taylor
and Marie Robinson they're like are you
guys [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
and in all this other stuff so there was
like a confrontation now at this stage
this is kind of weird because and and
several members of the congregation have
attested to this going on so Christine
confronts him about are you having an
affair with her what the [ __ ] is going
on and he starts to have essentially a
matram management um you know it's a man
tension that's a man tantrum yeah
obviously see hey your own word for that
yeah doesn't ask for the version of a
tantrum well a tantrum when I say
tantrum that usually means a child but
if it's a grown man okay okay I like it
you spawned that no I'm just saying the
mandrill it's a major it's kind of like
if it's a guy if a guy doesn't think
he's big enough he's got manorexia yeah
yeah man right see that's that's when he
gets like super obsessed with making
yourself bigger whereas like maybe you
have anorexia whether you're a man no
small enough you're not small enough so
you're trying to like starving anorexia
yeah is somebody that I didn't make that
up I bred that some real Peppa look at
this cat yeah she what's he doing come
here she's [ __ ] around come here man
charm I don't know if I made that upper
if I just I don't know that just seemed
like a very obvious epithet but yeah so
he has a man Terim now interestingly
like he starts acting like super weird
and like flipping out and stuff now
interestingly instead of attacking his
wife who was actively accusing him in
front of everybody of essentially I
don't know she's used these words she
probably didn't obviously this man you
guys gotta see this [ __ ] what is he
doing what the [ __ ] you doing like not
do anything yeah play that [ __ ] off yeah
so instead of like attacking his wife
who was the one actively accusing him at
the time he decides to go after Marie
the 21 year old there she now she's
moving the camera oh she's gonna push up
are you done are you done oh you're
being such a brat okay she just has to
be on the show she wouldn't be like
involved yeah she doesn't like it if
she's not involved so yeah so Michael
Taylor decides instead of going after
his wife who was actively accusing him
at the time he's going to go after Marie
the 21 year old pastor of the
congregation who he's supposedly super
in love with so he goes after Marie
he starts [ __ ] screaming at her
beating on her all this other kind of
[ __ ] so all these other members the
Congress like what the [ __ ] man and they
like jump on him and they have to like
pull him off of her and like restrain
him and [ __ ] and they think that he's
just like losing his [ __ ] marbles at
this point now Marie later said of this
whole debacle she said that you know I
looked at the guy she said his whole you
know the whole contour of his features
changed she said he looked beastial
quote unquote that he
like an animal said he kept looking at
me and there was a really wild look in
his eyes I started screaming at him she
started speaking in tongues is she
saying her than him I guess she didn't
kill anybody later but you know what I
mean she still had that thing going on
she says Mike which is what she called
them also screamed at me in tongues I
was on the verge of death and I seemed
to come to my senses now she says that
the only way that she got him to stop
beating on her and screaming at her
whatever was her shoes she just kept
yelling like Jesus Jesus Jesus at him
because that's what they always ask you
and you know so she says oh thank you no
thank God that I wasn't killed he might
have killed me and stuff which would be
you know he very well may have
considering what happened later on now
when Michael Taylor was kind of snapped
out of the fugue that he went into I
guess like after this incident he said
that he didn't remember any of it I
don't know if that's true or not but
that's what he said anyway so the next
day he goes back to the congregation and
he says you know I don't remember any of
it and all of the congregants there
actually forgave him and gave him like
an absolution because that's what they
do I don't know it's like I want to say
oh they're better people maybe there's a
crazy way they're just more naive people
pray to it I prayed it away now they
don't pray in the gay way but yeah you
can do it but you can't be afraid but
yeah you can't you can't pray away face
ripping either especially in this case
so even though they did say that they
forgave him they did the whole like
trust but verify thing because he said
okay we're still gonna keep an eye on
this [ __ ] because we don't know
like what he's capable of he may be
crazy we're not we're not quite sure
so as time goes on both his wife and
other members of the congregation note
that his behavior is just getting worse
and worse as I said he was very nice
mild mannered person before but now that
he is big
involved with this call to become
involved with Marie Robinson he is just
getting like crazy and crazier crazyer
his behavior is becoming stranger and
stranger more violent he's going into
these outbursts and all this other kind
of [ __ ] now at this stage some members
of the congregation and some other like
kind of pastors that were like adjacent
to this little religious group they
decide well maybe he has been subjected
to demonic forces perhaps he is
possessed
maybe so we should position that cat's
back in that closet see every time we
record the show she's like why are you
guys not paying attention to me it's hot
it's hot it's the summer and she doesn't
want to go outside so she can't blow up
steam it's like a little kid yeah yeah I
mean yeah in case you don't know like
we've been doing before we live in
Central Florida
it's like Dagobah it is hot as [ __ ]
balls here right now and humid as balls
also so previously during the winter she
will little Pookie will go outside and
she'll run around in the yard for a
couple hours and then she'll be fine and
she'll come back in she'd be like E
Hagin omelets I killed some bugs I did
some [ __ ]
mmm you know but when it's summer she
does not want to go outside because yes
she's miserable outside so she will just
stay in here yeah and mess with us and
climb all over right here and just which
you know she just wants to be involved
with mommy or daddy doing that so right
mommy and daddy as if we gave birth to a
cat I can't understand it it's the only
girls covetous [ __ ] hey you it's a cat
you call yourself daddy - no just don't
I'm just joking though you sound like
you're serious okay but that's what just
earlier we were like putting the laundry
away he's like go see mommy and yes I
was well yeah you were and then and then
you like you got me to do that you like
make me sound crazy okay hey stop it all
right so like I said they start to think
well maybe there's a demon possessing it
maybe that's what's wrong so they they
consult the local vicar and they decide
that that maybe they should do an extra
so they get to ministers and I guess
they were both from around there one of
them and this cracks me up his name was
father Peter Vincent which of you guys
have seen right night from 1985 that was
the name of the vampire killer that was
played by Roger McDowell is it yes in
your veinte oh yeah so yeah this was a
real guy Peter they didn't get the name
from fright night it was a real guy and
then there was another guy named
Reverend Raymond Smith and they were
brought in to do an exorcism on Michael
Taylor so they were gonna do it at
midnight for whatever reason I guess
that's the same reason like why in
movies it's like we're gonna turn off
his life support it in midnight we're
gonna do the exercise yeah because it's
like for like okay as the day does
change us tonight
or the day changes to the next day right
so they're gonna do it at midnight on
October 5th 1974 and this is at a church
in Barnsley
so I guess there were like a bunch of
other congregants there and they were
kind of watching it too the two
ministers start just okay they get stuck
in and they're doing the whole exorcism
on Michael Taylor trying to rid him of
whatever demons it was so it goes all
throughout the night and they're trying
to get rid of the demons now as soon as
they start doing the ritual Michael
starts doing your standard exorcism
stuff he starts like spitting and biting
and swearing at them and they eventually
ended up having to tie him down because
he was just thrashing everywhere and
like smacking everyone um so the first
exorcism last like eight hours he's um
they're doing [ __ ] to him like you know
they're [ __ ] throwing holy water I'm
they're sticking crucifixes in his mouth
and all this other kind of stuff you can
see his eyes
I was thinking that too because when I
was reading like somebody's just like I
said I wrote about that might be more
effective it's like sticking up his
buddies like oh that's like surprised
the demon out of him hey no but stuff I
didn't sign up for that but yes
so yeah so there's stuff and stuff in
his mouth as far as I know I don't they
might in a second in his button they
just don't want to tell anybody but so
you know he's acting like I all
animalistic like growling at them away
now so now at this point and this she's
doing oh what's where is she I don't
know okay oh I know where she went she
went under the desk there was a shelf in
the desk and she's looking around in
there alright so the two priests come to
the conclusion and this is some warrens
level [ __ ] right here they come to the
conclusion that Michael Taylor is
inhabited by not one not two not even
three but forty demons
yeah like forty thieves like Ali Baba
that's what I mean for me it's a nice
round number Friday you're gonna have
demons and you just wait - now each of
these demons apparently had a different
function I guess so got your demon of
bestiality guys your demon of carnal
knowledge got your beat got your demon
of heresy got your demon of masochism
you got a demon for each letter these
are very very specific low-level demons
funny that there's they each have one
little area that they specialize in and
you need a whole bunch of them to
possess one person to get the whole
range of activities I guess I don't know
if this works what's funny is that there
was a demon of bestiality and I recall
reading a book about demonology and
there was some comments on it they said
there were a lot of you know transcripts
from from like inquisitions that
happened on yeah you know if it was
supposedly you know possessed type
people this is bragged of it yeah
sixteen hundreds and evidently the one
of the questions was is you know did you
have sex with animals and he always
asked girls this have you been having
sex with the animals because they were
fantasizing yeah there was some where
didn't
evidently the oles tell me you [ __ ] a
horse please yeah yeah yeah
evidently you know some of the
commentary was is that that a lot of a
lot of the priests back of the day we're
very interested to find out whether or
not these young women were having sex
with animals oh I'm sure they were very
we have porn for that now yeah
makes you wonder you know I mean that
there was a couple cases where you know
guys admitted to having sex with things
with animals and they killed him and the
animal but you know I don't I don't I
can't recall any in the readings that he
came across some of those old books
whether or not a woman was to actually
ever caught red-handed having sex of
these animals this sounded like
something priests were breaking up there
wonder you haven't sex yeah like I could
see how cuz look it's you know there's a
handful of freaking toys nowadays
they're into like be really like I've
seen some of those websites and yeah not
a purpose or anything but it's like I've
seen a couple in this so I know there's
people that it's into that but it's
gonna be like a way smaller percentage
than people that fantasize about other
people doing yeah which is why there's
porn of it nowadays in the first there
seems to be there seems to have been
kind of like in the demonology bracket
you know in France and England
yeah the priests were very to figure was
a racket yeah it was a racket you know I
mean think that the priests were very
interested in people's sex lives you
know they wanted to know like I said
they didn't have internet porn back no
they had to get their jollies somewhere
yeah they had to have something that
they could think back on later on when
they were jerking it well I think I
think you know that that made brought I
couldn't was looking cross we kind of
project and probably projecting modern
mentality dude I think they I think
there's a lot of curiosity about I do
not think so mostly I will honestly I
think that people back then yeah there
was a lot of differences but I think in
that aspect I think people back then
were just the same I think I think a lot
of these priests were we're imagining
people to be more you know I mean Wow
then they were I think there was some
wild chicken well yeah I mean the
[ __ ] goes on but I think people think
it's more
and then it is so I think people think
oh it's like do you know it must be
pretty bad so we're like these beautiful
20 year old maidens were out there in
the barn just like having the horses
yeah yeah they gotta be cuz you know
like rail then that's the way they're
thinking but that's yeah that's what
they wanted to thank you was that
happening maybe in like a tiny
percentage but not as often as the
priests would have liked yeah have
occurred maybe they maybe they read
about it happening somewhere else
and then they were like and they're like
oh well this must be a common practice
at all like to my mom and women that are
possessed you know that mean something
like that weird
I just they made up all that kind of
[ __ ] just that if they're like weird
imagination they could they didn't have
access to the raw data like they didn't
have access to the raw data so they
could just like kind of a monopoly
whatever yeah it could just like line up
with whatever they were kind of into it
yeah it's like they didn't that could
easily [ __ ] that could easily end up
you know we got to stop these women from
having sex with all these animals yeah I
think that most of those like oh yeah
women haven't said like all those women
that got like take it like for
witchcraft and Cher you don't really you
don't think that like the priests were
like listen to all they're like confess
like after they tortured these girls
yeah and they were like I'm gonna be
like yeah whatever what do you want to
hear these are just like making up
stories and they're like oh those dirty
[ __ ] and they went back to their
[ __ ] rooms later on in there oh yeah
yeah well they were having sex with
women - I mean we need these priests
back in the day we're having sex with
women they have had they may have been
happy it was like boring but it's like
they were kind of thinking of like oh
we're supposed to have second they were
having hunters undercover sex with nuns
yeah they had stuff going on orphan
their children were in orphanages they
had all it was a racket
That's not me it was all kind of
horrible [ __ ] god I'm back documented
this is documented I'm making this up
yeah so alright so they're doing this
exorcism on Michael Taylor and I think
we got into the whole thing because we
were like talking
sticking crucifixes oh yeah our demons a
bestiality what's the time I don't know
okay don't know feels like it's been
hours no okay just you you don't you
have like some weird time distortions
yeah I'm John well some of mine but I
don't have a time distortion okay okay
so you see you have a bit of grass for
the space-time continuum yes that I do
yes even when you're inebriated yes okay
well that is it now people heard that
that is a documented fact to be
fluoridation
all right side note she becomes Spock
when she gets drunk no I'm just saying
I'm still Kirk so they do this
eight-hour exorcism on this dude
sticking crucifixes in his it's not as
butthole as far as I know but maybe I
don't know okay so they said that during
this first exorcism which just plum wore
them out you guys um they had to stop
because they were all tired because it
really takes it out of you like yelling
at a person that's strapped to the floor
I guess now they said that they were
able to rid him of most of the demons
okay however and I'm not really sure how
they know this so I so don't like ask me
but apparently three of the demons that
were still in there like they were able
to run out the bestiality one the
blasphemy one and like kind of all your
lower you know your miter leave demon
right yeah they ran all of those out
supposedly but the ones they left in
there were three demons specifically
these were the insanity demon the anger
demon and the murder demon which you
think you'd want to get those out first
yeah this is the hardest one I mean why
don't you leave like okay if you're
doing an extra sub just saying firm tip
if you're doing an exorcism why don't
you like start with the big ticket demon
it's like it's your murder demons out
get your leg [ __ ] get all that [ __ ]
out like you can leave like the
jaywalking demon in there
you can leave like the [ __ ] illegal
parking probably whatever just other get
they're getting it the easy demons out
first but I guess that doesn't do I
think it's easy but they were just like
oh well there's only three demons left
they're like the worst ones but we're
saving those for the last we're so tired
you guys it's like I really have to go
home and watch Netflix and have a drink
put my feet up I can't deal with this
anymore so we're just gonna leave this
poor dude with these three the three
worst demons and we're gonna leave them
in there well this the ones they
couldn't get out I guess okay that's
what they'll tell you anyway I'm just
what happened I'm not buying it so they
said okay well we'll continue the
exorcism tomorrow because these three
demons are still in there and these are
the worst ones so we have to get them
out yeah now apparently there was a
woman and she was one of either one of
the congregants or like the wife of one
of the ministers or something and her
name was Margaret Smith and she came
forth to two of the exorcism she said
you guys you really have to like
continue the action get these three out
because I think something really really
bad is gonna happen
all those demons are still in there he's
gonna kill his wife
evidently she did warn them of this
ahead of time and the priests were like
man we just we can't do it anymore we
just have to know them and sleep we
can't take it so they left it and they
said we'll continue this tomorrow after
everyone's rested so as you can probably
tell this did not end well yeah they had
honest Jews so about 9:45 the following
morning which was October 7th 1974 this
was two hours after Michael Taylor and
his wife Christine had gone home to rest
for presumably the next exorcism where
the three worst events would be it would
be you know exited from his body
so there's a police patrol car it's kind
of driving through the streets doing its
regular little rounds or whatever in
acid in West Yorkshire and they see a
naked man running down the middle of the
street just covered from cuff
blood from head to toe now right so
thinking this is a little unusual right
they stop and ask him man
what's the tail and he starts screaming
and ranting and stuff this is the blood
of Satan so obviously this is not good
now as they're talking to this man like
a bunch of other towns folk come around
and they said hey that's Michael Taylor
they just exorcised him and now he's
running around naked covered in blood so
they give the police his home address
now
this cop car goes to the home address
now by the time they get to his home
address there's already another cop car
that had been called by neighbors who
had been worried about some kind of
commotion like coming from so now so
they're already converging on so they're
already converging on this house now the
cops go in there and just like in the
movies the first cop that goes into the
house immediately runs back out and
throws up and he be and here's the quote
I don't know if this is accurate but I
found this quote like online of what
what the what the first cop said like to
the next cop he didn't want them to go
in there he says you don't want to see
this one son yeah I've seen nothing like
it before and I've seen a few it's the
wife she's got no and then there's like
an elliptical what she doesn't want to
happen he's like there's not much of her
left you don't want to see it
so eventually obviously since they're
cops they have to go in the house what
they find when they go in there to
complete the whole living room the whole
front room of the house is just
completely destroyed this [ __ ]
everywhere just as broken stuff working
furniture everything there's blood
everywhere
there is pieces of brain everywhere
there's pieces of little gobbets of
flesh everywhere on the floor of the
living room is the body of Christine
Taylor the wife of Michael Taylor also
their pet poodle now Christie LDC well I
don't think he [ __ ]
what was the blood that was out now when
they found Michael Taylor running around
in the street like naked and covered of
blood that wasn't his blood that was his
wife's blood and he was covered with it
head to toe what did you do it oh okay
so he had taken off all her clothes
first of all he had torn off her entire
face with his bare hands
damn so no sign of any weapon he and use
a knife nothing like that he had gouged
out her eyeballs yeah he had ripped out
her tongue and then had just started
tearing like after she was unconscious I
don't know if she was unconscious or
dead or whatever he just started digging
into her face and tore her whole [ __ ]
face off they don't know if that was
done postmortem down to the bone they
said she was unrecognized so they don't
know if she did that to her after she
was dead well they said when they did
the post-mortem they did they determined
that she had actually the cause of death
was officially asphyxiation from her own
blood she had choked on her own blood
that's how she died
so yeah tearing her apart while she was
away yes yeah yeah and as if that wasn't
bad enough and that's horrible enough he
had also gone after the dog I think was
a little poodle yeah he had strangled it
and then tore all legs off with his bare
hands right yeah
okay just why the demon did it so he did
all that and he ran down the street and
got arrested what happened to that to
that say yes so like I said the cops
were just like they said they've
obviously they'd never so [ __ ] cops like
this and cops here of Denver seen
anything like this
what year again was this 1974-75 1970
obviously they arrest Michael Taylor
they take him into custody
and he was still ranting and raving it
took him several hours to calm down
they finally interviewed him and were
like brah what happened there so now he
did tell them about the exorcism um and
the quote that I found from him was that
he said it was a long night they danced
around me and burned my cross because
that was tainted with the evil they had
me in the church all night look at my
hands I was banging on the floor the
power was in me I couldn't get rid of it
and neither could they they were too
late I was compelled by a force within
me to destroy everything living within
the house now he later said that again
he had no memory of what he had done to
his wife and he was apparently very
upset about it when they told him about
it because he said that he had loved his
wife and hadn't wanted to do anything to
hurt her but he said that he remembered
that he thought that she was possessed
by a demon and so that he had to kill
her to get rid of it mmm that was kind
of this story that he told because one
of his later quotes was the evil in her
has been destroyed I'm released it is
done right so it's almost like he
thought she was possessed or something
like that like he had to do it so at
this stage they're like okay well this
[ __ ] crazy so they sent him to a
psychiatric hospital and they couldn't
decide like whether they were gonna put
him on trial for a murder whether they
were just gonna like slam him an insane
asylum or what now they said that while
he was in custody like awaiting like
what they were gonna do with him they
said he was either sleeping or he
wouldn't talk I don't really know what
happened cuz they had five kids now
apparently the five kids were either not
home they've been sent away at the time
because the kids weren't killed they
weren't in the house at the time I guess
they didn't see any of it hopefully they
didn't I don't know what happened to
them subsequently like how they reacted
to this whole situation but there was
just like a whole like [ __ ] obviously
this is what this tiny lil
West Yorkshire what you know dude like
rips his wife's face off kills the dog
and makes its legs off and [ __ ] like
that and what is that he didn't remember
it what they do so what they did like I
said it was a big media frenzy or
whatever now the trial started in March
of 1975 and they said that basically
they were trying to go for an insanity
defense right because he said that he
didn't report it happened he was
possessed by demons
it didn't evade capture or anything no
no that's what I mean he was just blood
definitely and he said I thought she was
possessed by demons or I'm possessed by
demons it's like yeah that's why I did
it right so they basically what they
tried to do was that the defense I mean
other than putting forth the in the
insanity defense they were also trying
to lay some of the blame on the kind of
religious group or occult if you want to
say that he was involved with saying
that maybe they were part of the blame
because today yeah because like if he
really did believe that he was possessed
by demons that he wasn't really than
they were encouraging that belief by
doing all the exorcism so they were kind
of trying to like you know a portions
and blame there as well so they were
trying to like paint it like it was a
super like fanatical cult and maybe they
had some culpability in that issue then
that issue and I think like one of the
guys that testified at the trial even
called the cult quote in neurotics
feeding neurosis to a neurotic okay so
that's kind of insane people messing
with an insane guy
exactly exactly so as the trial went on
I think really the only thing they ended
up establishing that he was indeed
insane he didn't really seem to have any
motive for what he did he didn't seem to
have much memory of it or if he did he
seemed to believe that it was
demonically inspired so they ended up
putting him in the infamous Broadmoor
psychiatric hospital which where they
usually put criminally insane people
back in the day and the
you okay and they stuck him in there so
he was not guilty by reason of insanity
okay the question okay did anybody
witnessed anything that was paranormal
um
psychokinesis this I don't think that
there was any psychic locus involved is
all that was involved was a drastic
change in personality in a very brief
time so the courts may have been right
about this one these are crazy people
acting on the minds of a crazy
[ __ ]
yeah loses it that sounds plausible
that's what I mean it seemed like he was
like a nice relatively normal dude he
was suffering from depression but a lot
of people do it's not that unusual they
drove him crazy somehow and then he gets
involved in this religious group which
somehow like feeds into his depression
and like delusions and stuff and yeah
ideas break he has a mental breakdown I
do feel like that that was probably you
know the situation here that's what it
sounds like to me so I do feel like the
court probably made the right decision
they put him in Broadmoor insane asylum
because they determined he was not
guilty by reason of insanity you know
legally insane so they put him in there
now he was only in there for two years
then they transferred him to another
psychiatric hospital for another two
years but then they let him out so he
only did four years yeah now there was a
whole like brouhaha like after because
like I said he'd only served four years
and this was like a super horrific
murder by any stretch of the imagination
there was a whole controversy about the
church actually the exorcism that was
performed on Michael Taylor was actually
the last exorcism that the Anglican
Church ever provide as far as I know
they haven't performed any more since
then just because of the scandal like
surrounding this particular case because
they kind of got a little bit of the you
know backlash of like blamed of it like
maybe they had something to do with him
going crazy yeah so they didn't do
exorcisms anymore after that this is
like I said it's not the Catholic
churches the Anglican Church so yes so
he only served four years in a say
patric hospital now after they let him
out they said that he was alright and
then he wasn't a danger to anyone so he
goes back to living the same small town
again I'm not really sure how anybody
like felt about that or how they react
to do it I'm not even really sure how
his children reacted there's not really
a lot of information about that either
now after he went back to live and asset
apparently he was still like kind of
weird like people thought he acted like
very odd but not like violent weird like
no-one was scared of him or anything
like that um he did make several suicide
attempts over the ensuing years I
believe there were at least four that
they know of one time he jumped off a
bridge but didn't die even though he I
think he broke his back or broke his
legs or something like that or injured
his back and legs um another time he cut
his wrist there were a couple of other
attempts but after that he kind of like
went on the download there like wasn't a
lot of news about him now in 2005 in the
summer of 2005 he was arrested again and
this was for sexual harassment of an
underage girl now when he was arrested
and brought to trial for this particular
charge he said to the police
quote/unquote am I going to Broadmoor
for murdering my wife even though that
had been many years ago so evidently he
was in custody for about a week over
this and they while he was in custody
they noticed that like the psychiatric
problems that he had like the weird
behavior that he had been exhibiting
prior to that when they had tried him
for the murder of his wife was starting
to manifest once again like he was
starting to act like delusional so they
thought maybe they should put him back
into a psychiatric hospital but I guess
they kind of assessed him and they said
well he's at minimal risk I mean he was
much older at this point so they said he
was a middle
minimal risk for reoffending so they
just gave him three years community
service and made him get psychiatric
treatment and essentially let him kind
of run around late I just wanted to keep
an eye on him
yeah now as far as I know since 2000
since his last arrest in Tucson 2005 he
has not reoffended he has not you know
yeah
come into the media book which you think
that he would like if he did anything
bad like you think everybody would be
jumping all over that is basically the
end of that case but that's pretty much
it like he's pretty much I don't even
know if he's still alive at this stage
that doesn't sound paranormal to me that
that's it that yeah that to me like I
said I wanted to put these two cases
together because they were both like
well they were both like demon
possession that was supposedly they
caught us from breath but there's a big
difference between in two cases that
they have a lot of a lot of credible
witnesses to it mm-hmm
a paranormal phenomenon you know I'm
kind of buying into that I mean I wasn't
there to see it but that sounds like
that's a good case well the fact that
someone that was you know a
board-certified psychiatrist yeah he had
studied and presumably I mean he wasn't
a dummy he had like he was a doctor he
had studied that kind of like the top
university in the US and he thought that
maybe there was something to this case
you know yeah that kind of gives it a
little bit more legitimacy because I
feel like a lot of cases of
quote-unquote demon possession you know
the only people that are saying yet
happened are people who have a vested
interest in that being real like priests
yeah is essentially you get accounts
from priests and I'm not saying the
priests are dummies I'm just saying that
they have a vested interest in demons
being real there's a good show yeah you
think yeah but yeah so you know if
you're insured in the Michael Taylor
case that was priests some pretty [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
yeah I don't know if he's still running
around out there he might have died at
this point he was 31 in 1974 so your
idea he might be really old or dead
right now but he'd really didn't come
into the media anymore after 2005 so I
don't know what
and to him after that which is kind of
strange like that nobody kept track of
him for all this especially like the
British tabloid media you'd think they'd
be like he fell to the grass all the
writers got old and then a new new bunch
came in I guess so yeah but yeah you
tear your wife's face off and I guess
you can get away with it if you crazy
that's pretty sad not here you'd be
locked over the rest of your life here
the United States yeah you probably
would never know even if you were crazy
they would never let you out they would
put you in a psych yeah they make it
worse
if you were crazy well they might be in
a psychiatric are a but they wouldn't
let you out back out on the street they
were just leave you in there so you died
yeah I'm sure they would all right sure
yeah so we've gone on wait long enough
yeah as we usually do so hopefully you
guys enjoyed episode 148 about the Julia
case and the Michael Taylor Exorcist
murder and remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you'd like to
financially support the show it would be
much appreciated you go to our patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
and there is a little paypal button in
the sidebar where you can go to a PayPal
account and give us a one-time donation
if you would like to remember our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
Monday if you're a patreon supporter
also we have movie retrospectives they
come out every Friday and 13 o'clock the
matinee which is three new movies in the
theater which we review that comes out
every Sunday so check those out if you
haven't already and we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]